non occupé occupé de nous excuser de
change constants pour le deuxième
épisode 2 la revanche fait un ace combat
un jour finir cette peinture tard c'est
ouf comme histoire vassiliou c'est
glauque douce mais oh là là sa part
carrément steak dans l'endroit oui
bonjour à nicolas s'est bloquée je m'en
vais il n'y a plus de porte
y a plus du tout comme [ __ ] c'est trop
bien fait ouais j'suis peut ni on est au
coin si je tourne en boucle et mais ne
portera pas mal mais oui c'est génial
c'est trop bien comment je passe olalala
non mes mecs
non mais mais hollywood effets spéciaux
être jeune c'est trop me refais [ __ ]
tu as tu te retournes à pau et et la
pêche change totalement quoi oh [ __ ]
c'est là le mec kouilou une pince fait
pas semblant quoi moi je trace un j'ai
pas le temps restless memories olala il
ya du sang partout
non il n'a pas de but et la personne
comme moi tu as fuck le décor au plafond
en fait
ok j'ai allumé la lumière ça nous a bien
l'endroit non mais mon gars faut y aller
pour comprendre tout ce qui se passe
dans le jeu un ca à quoi ça a retourné
la gueule à l'ascenseur elle ce parti le
jeu est bientôt finie mais [ __ ] qu'est
sa part en steaks
on note ici ok donc la scéne l'aide de
son agent qui est aussi son ami il dit
je peux pas croire qu'elle a elle mis le
feu à thésée vieilles peintures pourquoi
elle aurait fait ça la dame en noir
surtout c'était un hommage à elle n'est
ce pas je ne sais pas quoi te dire tu
devrais probablement parler à quelqu'un
paye tout ce qui est arrivé je suis sûr
que ça te fera du bien
je n'ai sûrement pas besoin de te dire
que l'acheteur a été déçu de ces
nouvelles les nouvelles pièces ne se
vendent pas aussi bien que les
classiques
bref je vais continuer à chercher tu es
juste là et concentre toi sur ton
travail je sais que tu as toujours ça en
toi je crois en toi ok et lui il a
répondu non allez courage tu vas faire
de belles peintures non les sur nous on
croit en toi fais une chaîne youtube en
fin de vidéo en stop turc est libre on
fera du 2e v2 c'est quoi ça c'est ouvert
ça ça se faire non non non casse toi tu
te retournes dans la pénombre
ok on avance on avance toujours tourner
la pièce avec des trucs là le bon ok
c'est par là je sens qu'on va trouver la
petite femme un peu chelou un moment où
l'autre le bon piano
au hockey parfait mec tâche qui
fraîchement espace à la fois posée sur
mon canapé je vais jusqu'à mon pc comme
ça c'est magnifique c'est super beau oh
là là mais mec c'est incroyable qu'elle
fait quelques fois qu'elle fait ça se
fait lui coûte une main jouée en direct
on ya un coffre yaakov qui volent j'ai
besoin de retirer le schéma quadéo je
savais pas faire comment mais ensuite je
les fais ok d'accord en gros il a broyé
un os et il a mélangé les poussières de
saïda peinture je sais pas quoi non mais
d'autres dans l'atelier est ce qu'on va
faire la suite de la peinture mon gars
là c'est dû à quoi c'est dû à quoi
ça commence à prendre forme sa peinture
avec du sang et de poussière dollars à
taussat profond pour faire un truc
dégueulasse j'avais besoin de retirer la
chair des os et je savais pas comment
faire avec la luxe et la poussière de
side de la peinture blanche et ça a
donné une superbe sous couche suffit je
me casse
et si tu rates et battus et à 9 oui ça
c'est un ya du suspense de la peur
ignore la non mais m'bia le fuck what is
love baby dont les surfaces pour faire
redescendre la pression je m'excuse
voilà sheryfa luna
non mais là ça part sacrément cool mon
gars non mais là au regard des noms mais
je sais plus parler aux mecs c'est
tellement flippant j'y vais j'y vais on
est des bonhommes et des bonhommes on
elle est là elle est là
du coup d'un coup 4 à 1 on y va au liban
je suis à bloc
non mais cette femme faut qu'elle arrête
quoi moment c'est beau la justice dans
un mixeur pour faire la peinture ya pas
de quoi s'énerver
on se relève calmement et on y va allez
on y va c'est parti on s'amuse des rats
partout à les cas les peintures des
formes toit avec des rats j'aurais
pleuré
c'est incroyable comment ses bienfaits
même les décors les trucs elle va
arriver demain c'est sa femme femme
peinture iloveyou on a reparu l'art en
position foetale dans ce cercle de
bougies talking sa part dans ton dos oui
oui oui oui je vais marrer c'est joli
mais effrayant oh là là à la porte qui
te met jour là la même pièce doit noms
passés au crible
c'est [ __ ] deux rives la laisser assez
fermé j'ai entre eux ça me terrifie là
j'en ai marre une galaxie plateau de
crainte de bemba qui font peur aussi
redevenu beau au la chambre d'enfant
mignonne c'est intéressant mais le moral
est ok tout devient glauque tout de même
lot jean michel bloc'h arrêter ça presse
ça me stresse waouh c'est là peut-être
qui fait ça la fed a vu du beatbox quoi
y'a plus de respect non mais merde je te
bien fou
regardez à chaque fois sa tente sa
chance
ouah c'était intense bordel de merde à
c'est ma fille qui avait que ce
s'arroser qui ampleur et sa maman qu'est
mort c'est une brosse précis comme une
brosse en poils de cheval mais
différente à ce point j'ai hésité est-ce
que ça marchera vraiment fuck g terme
à mi chemin c'est pas comme si j'avais
tout oublié pour un problème d'accord ok
donc on a une mèche de cheveux au nickel
il a nommé la pop était sa fille maigre
et la [ __ ] et sa fille mec mais le mec
il bute sa femme sa fille son père rozon
chien tout juste pour faire un [ __ ] de
tableaux quoi et ça donne quoi
un [ __ ] de zombies voilà en quoi
c'était rentable de faire ce qu'il a
fait donc la toile c de la peau il a
fait la peinture avec du sang et de
poussière dos et il peint avec un
pinceau qui en fait les cheveux de sa
fille de nickel parfait [ __ ] on a
quasi finie mais c'est génial comme
histoire en vrai moi j'adore ça c'est
trop bien maison alleyrat à la maison
elle est ravagée mais qu à lui je le
déteste
je le déteste sabah au god c'est quoi ça
je suis quelqu'un peut faire que ce cher
ce tales à gratter des relais les murs
tout le temps il a pas but et le chien
what ce jeu tu es là tu fasses un mur tu
te retournes ya des cumines âge tu te
retournes il ya un bolide est passée il
peut se passer n'importe quoi ces
comparaisons merde ou baissent tous les
jurys sont comme ça avec oh là là oh là
là ça y est voilà voilà en une seconde
je me retrouve avec n'ont pas levé mais
pas le bébé
ok écran noir on se réveille de nouveau
dans une pièce devant mes fenêtres mais
c'est la foule
on va écouter [ __ ] je pensais pas que
ce serait aussi lourd ce juste consent
pire qu'une vidéo mais la selo bon je
vous propose c'est qu'on se retrouve
tout de suite dans une troisième vidéo
voilà et puis et puis j'espère que ça va
te la donne jamais ça a commencé par une
histoire il reste deux placards à ouvrir
là qui résume l'histoire j'espère ça
vous plaît c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
aimé la vidéo pour ceux ce mini let's
play a promis de verser de regarder en
tout cas on se retrouve dans une
prochaine vidéo tioté nouveau parti ou
bien pis jeter rifi
non non non sa chute